welcome to occasionally awesome Nick you
sir I'm Kevin crispy new new way to said
it different I just like yeah more of an
uptick on awesome because this episode
is super awesome they're all fun they're
all good episodes but some you know
little extra excited about yeah um
before we get into that stuff let's just
get some information out of the way um
do you have any gigs or anything coming
now steady failing steady rave up
straight up and pushed out ya gotta you
got Neil Neil parties under Neal Brennan
friends i'll be at the economy store
this friday and saturday um okay and
then I got um this month as like every
month for the past seven months the
workshop show new material new material
nite at The Comedy Store once a month in
the belly room this month is November
eighteenth lineup is coming together now
it'll be posted on the comedy store or
website the last one was great Nick
Swardson was there Jay Larson Emily
Heller I host all of them and then
really funny comics come work on brand
new material it's a really cool
laid-back fun show so this one's
November eighteenth I checked the
website for the lineup and get tickets
to that it's always a fun show December
16 through 19 I'm headlining the San
Francisco punchline and on friday
saturday i'm recording my next
so please come some of you have already
hit me up and said you've gotten tickets
thank you i love you but those of you
haven't get on that because I imagine
the people who are going are going to go
to the Friday Saturday ones before they
go to you know when is Wednesday
Thursday will be good but the friday
saturday and that's the weekend and
those are the ones i'm recording so get
tickets to that they're not expensive go
to my website Nicki Yousef calm / or /
gigs or just go to the live nation site
of the punch line side they're all and
there's a link in my Instagram and I
have a tweet that's pinned it to my page
was a very top one so this is very easy
it's like a one or two step process you
go to one of those things click the
thing get the tickets um let's see I
ordered those pins I keep talking about
right so I'm gonna have I'm gonna have
merge or little piece of merch little
little soft enamel pins they're going to
look super rad and once they come in I
we'll be able to buy them on my website
oh I'll tweeting Instagram some photos
of them in all the links and stuff we're
probably gonna have a another podcast
shirts in that's a fear in your eyes
right now Kevin when I mention that you
like truly the fear in my right wrist uh
yeah yeah i think i've circled what i
would like to draw whoa so this is and
now I did never drive because last time
it took this whole process took seven
months I think from I got a couple ideas
to I've narrowed it down you have to I'm
not saying we should but I learned from
last time in that I just have to keep
going so what's going on with that yeah
it's like how you like if you are dating
someone was perpetually late and you
want to be someplace by not leave by
nine you're like we got to leave at
eight yeah it's like that yeah and get a
key pilling no are you ready but get
ready yeah but hurry up though cuz we're
gonna be like he's got a lie you don't
say anything there's traffic yeah if you
don't be saying so but i think i'm gonna
take a second shower you're like no yeah
so that's good yeah thanks for keeping
me in the loop on what it was i have no
clue
that's a reason I've ever heard it's got
a fit in it's got to put into the line
of the history of its kind of faith in
the devil has to fit into the rhythm of
history of cotton art what what yes that
even mean it means something I know but
what does it mean it's right now the
people listening or going what what
needs to be a part of it needs to be a
part of the the t-shirt usual history ok
it has too much like a small you have
like picture like a river has to be like
a small ripple but not flat but it does
I don't want it to be like a splash to
where it's like begging that's just fit
into this that's the beat familiar and
different at the same time I know all I
was saying was last week you were like
yeah I got a few ideas and then then you
picked one but yeah thanks for letting
me know I mean it's not for sure for
sure but it's like I think it is how we
just add another three months of this
drop okay um let's talk about speaking
of making things right um Colin Hanks
you guys yeah uh first of all a
fantastic dude yeah good dude awesome
person a great actor now a director yep
guys he directed a documentary on Tower
Records which if you were born anywhere
I've been alive since the year I flick
1966 before to about two thousand six if
you are of the age where you could go
places and use your eyeballs you saw
giant buildings with a yellow and red
logo that there's Tower Records and they
sold everything yeah if it was music
they sold the music related yeah they
hit our video tower books they close in
2006 colin is a huge music guy yep um he
knows his stuff very well we always talk
about like about like cool music and
what he's into he's always in
pig rdio proponents big fan of our do
such a great streaming music app I would
say the best one and so he he for the
last what seven eight years yeah I was
working on this document and he's from
Sacramento grew up there so he was going
to the original towers and stuff and
power closed in 06 and that was like
it's kind of heartbreaking if you're
like a music guy and spent a lot of time
to go in there or any record store where
yeah you having conversations you're
talking you love music it's like a good
place to be and discover new stuff and
like make friends so he put kind of all
those feelings up into into making this
documentary and it's out now it's uh
it's not out in every city but you can
find out the city's it's in now it's
spreading pretty much like weekly go to
Tower Records movie calm and you'll be
able to find the words blank we're not
going to list every city but it is or a
state but it is in at least 15 anywhere
from obviously California and like
Oregon to like New York obviously in the
North Carolina Tennessee Wisconsin so
it's like it's not just in them you know
the big cities that are in the end the
huge states so and it's I think it just
came out somewhere in canada in toronto
so check that website and see because it
will come to a city that you live in and
watch it I saw it last week it's really
good it's touching it's it's interesting
I learned a lot of stuff about that
company i did not know how huge it
really was yeah it's pretty fascinating
how big a got and the way it got big
it's pretty good thing yeah the way that
the way they ran it it was kind of like
a family operation sort of thing even to
when it got to 192
stores all over the world so it's a
really great story they did a lot of
groundbreaking stuff Colin did a great
job with it and and now you can see it
go support it support the movie support
Colin and his efforts I loved it and if
you live in LA obviously it's playing at
the arclight so go watch it there I
think that might be it right yeah and
let Colin Colin Hanks on twitter by the
way CEO Li nhan KS I let him know how
much you liked it you'd love to hear
that so follow them on Twitter or
Instagram or both and let them know what
you thought ma'am and we think again for
doing the show think that should do I
feel like that I'm having that thought
in the back of my head one forgetting to
mention something about the next week's
guest okay yeah we did record the
episode for next week and it's also a
[ __ ] Super Colon there's a book
coming out called The Comedians it's a
hundred year history of comedy off from
vaudeville all the way to like
podcasting basically which right now
you're thinking like Oh a two thousand
page book no it's like 400 ish or
something yeah it's a great read I read
it a couple months ago and I've been
dying the [ __ ] talk to people about
it and the author so cliff nesterov is
the author KL iph NE ste r 0 FF
originally from Canada did comedy for a
little while became a writer he's just
one of those old Hollywood guys alone
has a fascinating depth of knowledge
totally yeah
when it comes anything old Hollywood and
he knows a lot about comedy wrote a book
on it that book comes out next week I
think the same day as the episode so
that's next week's episode that one's
going to be awesome they had a really
cool conversation with him about where
he started when how long he did stand up
and then writing this book and like what
the hell that was like getting a hundred
year history of comedy into a book so
yeah that's next week's episode you guys
are going to love that one as well so
that being said let's quit rambling
ten-minute intros and things as long as
we go yeah we usually try to keep in
five or six but sometimes you got a lot
of cool information to tell people um
speaking of which last last last thing
if you like our podcast you guys you
always let us know I get a lot of emails
from you guys and I appreciate that I
answer every single one leave some
reviews on iTunes those help you know
leave like a five-star review or
whatever you're honest yeah you're
honest our review is and Lee and leave
like some kind of review one sentence to
sentence hey I love this podcast hey
[ __ ] you guys hey you should look what
you what your favorite episode was what
you like about us haven't got a great
body and as Kevin's level of
interrupting me lowered a little bit you
or keep those between
but yeah let us know because that helps
us ma'am okay that's it enjoy this
episode with a super awesome Colin Hanks
we're gonna start with thank you for
doing this and thank you for having a
tower records party dude I was so glad
that you came I'm so glad you asked me
to go he was gonna go but he had a buddy
in town and couldn't ya make it sorry I
told him I'm like so you're prepared to
miss the coolest most nostalgic thing
because he grew up out here too yeah and
he's like what am I about to miss and I
told him is it no like 90 zanet accident
that was super crazy was and what's
funny is it didn't occur to me until
like the next day but I've been so
focused on throwing this party you know
at the Tower Records and painting it up
yeah trying to find a way to pay for it
all that it didn't occur to me that
people were going to see the movie a big
deal perfect people are finally going to
see this movie I've been talking about
non-stop for seven years yeah and then
they're gonna have this like melancholy
moment hope yeah and then they're gonna
drive down the street and see it and go
in it and you know I mean it's not the
same and we don't have like stacks of a
records and [ __ ] like that but at least
it was like you know this great way to
like celebrate what they did and it
didn't occur to me until I saw all these
people like walking in and it's like as
close to you know adults going into like
Disneyland for the first time right when
ya huge Disneyland fans you know what I
mean yeah the look of pure joy on adults
faces was so cool it was great just
walking up that ramp I was like I never
thought I'd do this again and yeah and
at our record it made just the pictures
of it made me go how is this not
sustainable just for this one like
cancer just be this one yeah that's what
I found my something like there's not
one incredibly rich dude was like you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna make
one tower records and make one wicket
record store left like you can't have
this one please is the name still like
the name is now currently own the IP the
intellectual property is now owned by an
entity and they're trying to decide what
to do with it they've just sort of been
been squatting on it for a while yeah
there's still at our comm that runs it's
not very well run yeah I mean it's not
it's not a very good website it's
basically like an Amazon ish type uh-huh
but I don't know I mean we'll see what
what transpires I mean my hope is is
that somehow this movie kind of I don't
know juggles you know jingles you know
the feel it feels like it would whispers
the stuff that's been in there since at
least the Sun the Sun symbol of our one
isn't rad ya know and you want to know
what it's funny that sunset store in
particular that's been like the cream of
the crop in terms of stores are going
there's a there's a tower down in brea
okay um and it's just a furniture store
like really just an empty store with
furniture and they basically just put a
tarp up that says furniture and put it
over records so it's in our firm oh my
god super but it's such a bummer [ __ ]
downer but yeah I mean you know I don't
know flippa Graham was in there for a
while that didn't really make sense but
at least they kept the building nice it
was better than that sort of like cheesy
clothing store their clothing stores
yeah like I felt that the name involved
lots of exes yeah yeah that was kind of
a bummer the good news is now Gibson has
that lease on that spot oh well yeah so
they're gonna they're going to do
something with that space they're going
to try and keep it as spiritually music
II safe yeah which is cool so they were
the ones that actually like you know
helped us you know throw the party yeah
oh nice paint it up and all that sort of
stuff and and most you know we'll see
how long that name can yeah there on
that wall what was you the initial like
gave you the initial desire to do this
cuz you said you've been working on for
seven years yeah so basically growing up
in Sacramento I spent a stupid amount of
time
in Tower Records growing up I've been to
that Tower Records s the one where
Metallica blade they had a con watt
Avenue store yeah yeah so that yeah
that's the one that sort of featured you
know prominently in in the movie and so
growing up in Sacramento it was always
you know sort of a big deal that tower
was from you know my hometown right and
all that I had a godmother that had
worked there now before I was born a
couple of my mom's friends did you ever
work their dollar no no I applied twice
really yeah I applied in Marina del Rey
and in the one over up by third street
santa monica college and they both
pretty much said the same thing they
were like i asked for an application
they're like you know we could give this
to you and you could fill it out but i'm
just gonna put it on the stack of
applications yeah you know a knuckle
deep we're never gonna get to you so I
mean if you want to fill it out you can
and I was like oh food oh you never ever
heard from no no no strong at least they
were brutally honest I'll take that
right but yes so growing up I mean I
spent a lot of time just hanging out at
Tower yes you know I mean as most kids
do in high school there's not really a
whole lot to do you don't really have a
whole lot of money and until you start
like smoking dope and [ __ ] like that
right you're really just trying to kill
time and that was pretty much what I did
and so when the stores were closing I
found out about Russ Solomon and how he
started selling records so the founder
of tower he started selling used
seventy-eights out of his father's
drugstores father had like a classic
soda fountain americana drugstore in
this sort of iconic building in
Sacramento the tower theater building
and basically it was like they started
selling used 78 they sold out and so
then they bought new records and what
started off as like a little shelf in
the store you know started taking up
more space yeah face and then it had its
own like room and then it was the tower
you know
record Mart and there I mean there was
you know a couple of you know
incarnations of his sort of early you
know music merchandise retail business
but when I found out that it had started
like that I straight up said like that's
a documentary yeah I mean you know if he
starts like that and then closes 192
stores on five continents easy you know
50 something years is 60 something years
later like that seems like documentary
material yeah that's a story yeah and
then from that from that point that was
like the launching point for me to then
start you know doing a bunch of research
and finding out more about the company
and sort of learning about it's it's
sort of overall arc and its history and
then after I don't know maybe six or
nine months of like really doing a bunch
of research and sort of putting together
basically a team of my friends who all
grew up in Sacramento together who had
moved down here and it sort of started
you know their own careers down here in
la la' would we then made our pitch to
to Russ and he was the one that was
really adamant that you know it wasn't
necessarily his story that tower was
much bigger than he was right we needed
to talk to these other people because
they were the ones that were really
instrumental in making it what it was
and then it just sort of took on a life
of its own by that point it's I mean the
just the story of it is big and just in
watching the preview I started to think
about that every time I would be like I
remember I was like oh yeah you would
whenever I go to Chicago we would just
go to the tower records yeah that it was
and I started to remember like oh yeah
tower always had like the best magazine
section yeah like even it like I would
buy a CD but they would have liked all
the best magazines not even just music
magazine just magazines in general and
then they then they would have liked the
bet they would have a really good book
section like it functioned is like this
culture catch-all and we're wafer like
kids or if you wanted to be cool you're
like yeah you can buy t-shirt our
and be like not feel lame yeah no
absolutely it what it was um man I mean
I've been with this thing so long that
its kind of even I kind of have a hard
time remembering that you know at the
end of the day what we're talking about
is a retail business right whose sole
purpose was to sell you know yeah it's
tough to sell stuff make money and to
make money and all that stuff but there
is so much about what tower did that was
incredibly revolutionary and very
different from what the norm was at that
time that you know in you know 2,000
whatever we're in it's kind of hard to
to you know you don't think it's that
big of a deal but like the creating an
environment where you could go and hang
out and spend as much time as you want
to be completely entertained and yet
still leave without buying anything and
that being okay yeah yeah that's very I
mean that is not something anyone
recommends in a business class yeah what
I mean and even these little things that
helped foster that sort of aesthetic or
mentality or whatever really started off
very very early on like right at the
beginning and it just got bigger and
bigger and became much more of the
fabric of what our was like for example
in the 60s they opened up the first
proper Tower Records in 1960 and one of
the big things that russ was very
adamant about was that there was no
dress code now that does not seem like a
very big thing at all right but at that
time if you were a salesman in any
business you had to have a clean cut
haircut yeah you had to wear a suit and
tie and you needed to be incredibly
personable and trying you know walk out
on that floor and let's go sell some you
know what evers yeah vacuum yeah yeah
exaggerated cells washing machine yeah
and here's this company where they that
just wasn't part of the deal like you
just you could wear whatever you want it
you could
look however you wanted and not you know
albeit in the early 60s it's not that
you know style is not that radical do
you know what i mean but by 68 yeah
within eight years that becomes a very
big issue you know that becomes a very
big thing because all of a sudden you
have this total split between one
generation and the next yeah and that
younger generation is all about music
and you know trying to come up with
their own identity and you know all of
that sort of stuff that we now sort of
associate with pop culture youth culture
or anything like that yeah it it
probably makes me think that maybe that
was like the birth of the like kind of
not snooty but like record store
employee guy knew what was up who you
could be like the records record rip
yeah [ __ ] shreds dude or like you
would almost be embarrassed like dick I
wouldn't go to Tower Records and buy
like a lame record no because they're
not going to whoever works there's not
gonna be like that cool yeah this really
clitty dude bro well and especially if
you're spending a lot of time in the
store do you yeah so like it you know i
mean remember a couple times where it's
been like you know an hour two hours in
a store and I'd like think I know what I
was going to get and then I like spend a
good five minutes wrestling with like
all right so good should this be the one
yeah because they'd noticed that I've
been here for like two hours right so is
this the one I'm gonna you know put put
the credit on so to speak you know what
I used to do is as I would go in and do
that I would sandwich them so I'd get
like the thing that was kind of cheesy
so I'd be like I really like Gordon
Lightfoot and I know this like tattooed
snob but then I'd like above it would be
like a pantera record and then below
that would be you know like some punk
record was like your mind on else you're
like Gatorade yeah and I'm his magazine
so they look at it and I do this it
amoeba I still to this day will do this
cuz it's just you've conditioned
yourself so given the three records in
the gal go sweet bro and in the middle
one he'll just won't say anything but
they're like oh I got this one too good
but like the overall feels like you know
what you're doing but the middle
spoonful of sugar to help them be sure
yeah yeah no I know it I know it well
yeah I mean it was just there was so
much about tower that really celebrated
not only whatever was cool or popular
but really just all different kinds of
music you know and I think especially I
mean I think here in LA we're a little
bit spoke because we have an amoeba
which is like you know a huge record
store as you know all sorts of you know
new vinyl you know you CDs full you know
a whole room dedicated to classical
annoying music you know that's very very
rare but that was something that tower
did very very early on and their whole
their whole thing their main like
cornerstone was we're going to have as
much music as we can possibly fit into
this store you're going to have an
incredibly deep catalog we're going to
have as many of the albums from an
artist as we can possibly fit in so it's
not just hey you know our jazz section
is going to be you know Coltrane
felonious monk and Miles Davis is just
going to be like you know there are
three most popular records right right
and then we'll do that for every genre
they were like no we're going to stalk
this with as much music as we possibly
can and the more obscure [ __ ] there is
the better do you know what I mean yeah
the people that ran each store they
really ran it like it was their store
not like it was Russ Solomon store not
like it was tower store but like it was
there's one of the people in the in the
documentary made an interesting
observation where where she said
everyone at every tower felt like theirs
was the first yes and I was like I never
really thought about it till later on
but I was like I always used to think
the sunset tower was the first hour
record was at first yeah they just had
that feel yeah and that is really sort
of you know the really funny thing is it
is a hundred percent true in almost
every city and it shows you how special
they actually were because you know if
you're if you're feeling like that and
no one told you that
it's just an assumption that you're it
shows the quality of that store you know
where if you go to a tower records in
Nashville and you think that's the first
one you know like oh man yeah oh this
started here yeah that's like I mean
that's well they all feel local yes
because what they I mean you'd walk in
and be a bunch of local flyers around
are things for think it'll always that
aren't like worried about their job
they're just like hanging out yeah like
that's a guy that lives here is from
Mary works here yeah totally yeah you
know it's hard a hard thing to do to
pull off when you're like a
multinational chain yeah man I mean the
thing I realized in talking with Russ
and talking with those people that you
know they just they were there at the
very beginning of you know the sort of
like I said the sort of pop culture
youth wave whatever cool term you want
to use and I know that those are neither
cool terms but you know they were there
at the beginning and for lack of a
better phrase they were able to sort of
ride this ground swell of popularity and
with that they always kept like finding
themselves in the right place with the
right attitude and that was really sort
of the first that was when I started you
know researching that was the thing that
actually was most interesting to me at
first before I really found out what the
story was with you know all the
different people that work there but for
me it was just sort of more from a
historical aspect looking back and
noticing this trend where they would
kind of like pop up in the right place
at the right time with the right
attitude and it would become a success
and then yeah trot and then maybe they
try it again in another location so you
know they they open up this first store
in Sacramento in 1960 it does incredibly
well obviously the Beach Boys and all
this music starts coming in so they they
open up another two stores in Sacramento
so they sort of get a little bit of a
feeling for it Russ we don't even cover
this in the documentary but russ was a
concert promoter at the time oh really
well yeah so he booked the Rolling
Stones Beach Boys de Klerk y which at
that time keeping
mine is actually sort of a big deal
because Bill Graham is just sort of
starting to rise to prominence yeah he
was in on cisco and so it was kind of
like you know any band that was coming
through San Francisco rust would also
book in sacramento right so he opens up
these three stores and sort of does
pretty well and then he decides to
shutter the pros you know the
promotion's gig and just focus on stores
and so he you know that the San
Francisco how he finds in San Francisco
stories just yeah it's a good story it's
just ridiculous yeah um you know he
basically finds it hung over after a
night of womanizing right and and so
then he opens up that store and it's
march of 68 you know right before you
know I mean some people say the summer
of love is 67 I I wasn't there so I
don't really know obviously that's a
very important summer in the bay area
between you know berkeley in san
francisco and that whole sort of haight
ashbury scene right when it's all really
starting to become you know incredibly
well known i mean that that city for
lack of a better phrase about to be
invaded by you know hundreds of
thousands of dirty dirty hippies um and
so like the timing of that oh well how
how fortuitous that is able to to open
up this huge store light of that exact
exact moment you're about to be invaded
by throngs of people who want records
yeah and Russ actually says you know
it's like you know you can call it the
hippie move it but really it's the music
movement yeah reloads that defining you
know that the common thread throughout
all of that and then that becomes you
know that story becomes you know very
successful and then they sort of hit on
you know oh so this is this is what
we'll do we'll open up big stores with
these you know really deep inventories
you know because I mean you can say you
have a deep inventory but you know your
store really lets you know how deep your
inventory is well how much space you
have of course well now they can now
they know for a fact they can open up a
huge store and they just throw out
tables cup you know open up some
cardboard boxes and those are your
record racks you know you don't even
need to build record wrecks that stage
yeah and then within a few years they're
building their first or you know on
sunset yeah you know so that and you
know that alone is like oh I didn't know
tower built that store you know they
built it for 70 grand yeah but in like
it was a friend yeah that worked there
yeah Russ's cousin had fixed up the San
Francisco store and Russ's cousin Ross
like oh I'll help you build a store yeah
great so Ross and this guy Stan Gulman
who ended up becoming the COO of tower
he had you know 35 plus your career
tower he he helped build that store I
mean it's basically like you know two
dudes and a couple of workers every day
and they built that get stuck there what
how did he say it was built he's like it
was some it was a prefab that building
which basically just means that it was
it was already it's a rectangle it's
yeah it's basically just a rectangle you
know it's like a erector set you know
yeah this is here's how you build it
like one of those sheds you could buy
yeah pretty much what a great story to
shut down someone who works for you
who's like maybe being a dick you like I
built it with my hands yeah he's a [ __ ]
what was crazy was when we had the party
the other night Stan was there and I
said you know Stan if you go in the back
there you can still see the outline of
the tile he goes really oh yeah oh yeah
they still have like a dirt outline on
the concrete floor because Stan you know
says in the movie that he laid all that
tile with his that's I mean that's
incredible yeah it's a super cool and so
you know then it and then it just keeps
going it just keeps they keep doing that
over and over and over you know things
that end up becoming you know start off
is just like a crazy idea and you know
and or accident they just keep going and
keep going yeah this is the first Japan
or yeah the fair just like wow that was
a lot bigger than anyone imagined yeah
totally I mean I didn't know that they
went to Japan before they went to New
York me neither yeah so when I was like
doing all this research and I was just
finding out all of these little
interesting facts I go oh okay well this
is fascinating I really have this and
then once again like I said like once I
talked with Russ and found out just how
personable the company was and what a
what a family atmosphere was amongst all
the the people that work fair that's
when I said okay this is this is a this
story will work absolutely I know it's
just my job not to [ __ ] it up and try
and tell the best way i can write and
you did a great job thanks bones yeah it
was really good did I mean the family
aspect was so cool because I didn't know
a lot when you walk down a street you
know in any major city to see a tower
records you'd assume a you just assume a
bunch of dudes in suits run the place oh
I don't think it's like this music lover
former concert promoter like started to
snore hired as friends yeah when I think
it all on trust when I think about Tower
Records in almost in reference or sing
about feeling local I never in my head
thought there were that many of them I
was like oh it's too cool there's
probably like la Chicago Sacramento San
Francisco New York like in my head there
it was like one of the Sacramento on
that list would be only cuz I saw like I
live there for a summer in that and it
happened to be there was a contest that
you could win Metallica in your town oh
and they showed up with a flatbed truck
and played in second man yeah I was
there then I watch it on I was I was
down the street but I watched it on TV
yeah but they played at a local bar it
was pretty amazing to be honest with you
that was actually a whole big promotion
that they did where they wanted to do
three concerts in one day yeah because
they played Campbell earlier in the day
and then Sacramento was the evening show
and I think they're one of the other
location fell through yeah um but yeah
that was a big because I remember I was
in Sacramento and that was it that was a
big deal I always forget how much
Metallica means to northern
California so that when you banned yeah
you forget they're like a legit you know
when associated with San Francisco
really know me later yeah they like they
do the national anthem at like a 14
years game will it maybe last year or
something they're definitely on the the
anthem the circuit as I see like they're
doing it like Giants games a lot and
sharks I'll take a metallic anthem all
day right whatever you think you got
into like your big music fan yeah but
we've talked music you know your stuff
with your super into it yeah what like
when did you realize like oh I'm
obsessed with it like this is my part of
my identity I'm a music guy uh was
probably 91 okay um I was 13 or so I had
always been I'd always been buying
cassettes when I was younger you know
the first Beastie Boys record you know
raising hell by run DMC and was sort of
into you know I took a bus to school and
so it was really all about like having a
Walkman yeah listening to any of those
three songs on your way to school yeah
yeah but those three songs right oh man
this morning I'm gonna come in hysteria
or some sugar on me and then maybe you
know maybe I'll the first track on the
b-side I don't know we'll see we'll see
but so I had always sort of listened to
music as a kid my mom listen to a lot of
music in the car she always had the sort
of radio on in some way shape or form
and then over around 91 just so happens
to be that you know the year that I
tended to sort of have my own music
taste that maybe my parents were not
aware of yeah do you know what I mean
because it keep in mind like de Beastie
Boys run DMC that sort of stuff like
people those were that was a big enough
deal that my parents knew about it yes
but then once you get to
you know late 91 then it starts becoming
stuff that you know it becomes even
bigger but I latched on to it before I'm
not saying that I heard of it first
that's all right you can say that this
safe zone that is be like I'm a snob
when I discovered nirvana yeah when I
discovered nirvana I said these guys
with the bees name you got but that was
when all of a sudden my musical tastes
started really sort of going in a very
different direction from you know
everything prior and that's you know
they're never on a record it's the
program record it's you know blood sugar
sex magik whether Chili Peppers was a
Beaufort on out into Primus and the
meters and yeah Mike Watt and I mean
just all sorts of stuff and yeah you
know there was still you know a stuff
that was popular at the time that I
really dug to you know like I bought
that stone temple pilots record y'all
did I bought the hell did i bought the
concert tickets for that a terrible
right you know that's yeah oh [ __ ] I
forgot you can buy concert together like
you know that was another big deal the
thing that was where you go buy tickets
you know I like I don't I want now
trying to figure out what I bought
tickets for there cuz I've done it I
remember doing at least once and what
his face value there was no service fees
order ya bastard just like here's my
money and then they would give you your
ticket but yes so tower was really sort
of the tower and then there was a net
there was another there was another sort
of indie record store in Sacramento
called the beat that I went to a lot and
that one was actually sort of closer to
my house so when I was in the the pre
car days I would just ride the bike to
the beat and if you were really feeling
adventurous you know I could ride my
bike down to 16th of broadway and
sacramento to the tower yeah once i got
my my car watch it was it was a minivan
don't mind if I do yeah exactly thank
you hand me down that's when I started
going to the Tower Records a lot and
yeah and then that's when the really you
know the hanging
out talking with the people who worked
in the store you know trying to find out
as much about all the different kinds of
music that's when I really started to
get fanatical about stuff yeah that's
when I started to find out okay well
what are the bands that the bands that I
like like and sort of those kinds of
things okay well blood sugar sex magik
dedicated to my quad who's my blog
uh-huh okay he's this guy and he has all
of these different influences okay and
sort of learning about music that way
and at least hearing about you know
other things that you know no one in my
school was yeah I was talking about no
one in my school was was listening to
see like made friends with these record
store guys but you were like oh we have
these common interests yeah I mean learn
degree yeah yeah to a degree you know to
be able to sit there and and and talk
about stuff I mean I it took me a long
time actually took me a long time to
realize like it's okay if you don't know
[ __ ] yeah yeah they didn't know [ __ ] at
one point yeah learning from a different
dude and so you know there'd be like
well you know about you know this group
you're like oh yeah I know about them
and then wait for them to be you know
helping someone else and then I go and
have a rifle to this guy and there are
hoping you don't they could be like you
should check them out Fugazi what is
that I gotta go memorize an album real
fast okay all lied about knowing who
Fugazi was a black point exactly so but
yeah tower was definitely one of the
places where that really sort of took
hold so do you think now like where do
you think like younger people are gonna
go for that now because there's no like
physical place you can really like just
go shoot the [ __ ] about music and listen
to it and learn and argue and discuss
and like develop taste yeah I don't know
I don't so always asking me that the
other day and I really i don't know i
mean you could say that maybe starbucks
or coffee houses are the only equivalent
of that now like a basically a place
where you can go and hang out which is
really what tower was so as long as
there's a
place where you can go and hang out and
not get kicked out that's the only place
if you sort of go but you're not going
to bind you know it's not a bit not
really like a record store on you know
the likes of like a tower records sure
yeah you know so many people have been
asking me like you know do you think it
was better back then and I go it's not
better it's not worse it's just
different totally and that I think is
the big the big thing to sort of always
keep in mind because there's a lot about
you know the modern-day you know state
of affairs and music that i actually
think is [ __ ] awesome there really is
the options the options do i can find
pretty much almost anything yeah you
know within a relatively short amount of
time yeah you know I'm never going to
hear something is out of print you know
or if I want to try and find a record
with this obscure track I can find out
like I can find out what it was actually
called and I can look on like there was
a the best example of this is the ferris
bueller soundtrack ok there's an english
beat song that was a remix of march of
the swivel heads I had spent a decade
trying to find this kit I was like and I
found this song on the english beat
record but i was like what is the [ __ ]
how can i find that track well
eventually you know once I sort of found
out how to work you know a computer and
the internet were actually able to
[ __ ] find it not even bought it
because they didn't have that on they
didn't release that soundtrack anywhere
ever it wasn't released until two years
ago yeah and it was actually sort of
like a big deal and I remember uh like
finding that and I was like bought it
was like okay great and then it's a year
later they really that sound check is so
good that is definitely a pro there's a
lot of songs like that that urn like
there is that it's it's called I don't
know how to pronounce its French but in
European vacation is what
sounds like a like a French punk song
yeah sad blam boom wash ya in it yet
Santa it's like the catchiest thing in
the world yeah and I couldn't find it
forever yeah and we're not even getting
that up the other night it's such a well
it's a commercial right now to enough
that's what it's such a great song but
it's also not like I had it's also not
like normal French it's it's like Danish
French oh really they had a first
someone who speak French like listed
there like this isn't regular French
they are i can understand it relates
either and so it made it even harder to
find then someone just found it and
burned it for you but now you can find
if i googled it I put the first word in
of the song and the whole thing came
yeah yeah it's not a Chitty thing no
it's great it's a really amazing thing
and so like I really do miss uh you know
having a sort of place to go I mean how
we still have it with amoeba and there's
a bunch of other really great record
shops here in LA those are coming back
to like record stores are like starting
like little smaller out there small ones
and then then there they're coming along
and you know they're they're surviving
you know I wouldn't say that they're
thriving but they're they're doing okay
um but you know for like my kids you
know they're not really I mean I take
him to record stores but they're not
really gonna be you know I don't think
they're gonna be like oh we got dad we
gotta go to the record store yeah
because they're used to being in a get
[ __ ] right away again you know it's not
uh you know it's just different yes
that's all it is and and I just sort of
realized that it's just one of those
scenarios where everybody's just getting
older and they're going like things are
changing well welcome to it's called
getting older yeah it's gonna happen a
lot everything will keep changing
everything will keep changing and your
eventually we all just end up that
grumpy person that we made fun of when
we were you have to try really hard not
it's it is like an effort not to become
that grumpy person I did I try like with
music I just try and do both now where I
don't like just consume way too much
online because you don't really sit
there info
guess you don't listen to like full
albums are really get into an artist so
like I'll do a little bit like I'm only
gonna get these two albums on like Apple
music or already over every day and
listeners and then I'll go to an amoeba
or whatever local record store and just
walk in and be like what's playing right
now yeah I do that talk to the guy I see
Usher cuz the journey the discovery is
like where you stumble into cool [ __ ]
that that you wouldn't otherwise know
cuz that all those apps and and said
they learn about your taste and they
just kind of give you more of the same
yeah they don't need you down a road for
your life rent yeah totally yeah I want
different yeah I mean that's how I've
been functioning ironically I didn't get
into streaming until I started making me
smoke right but then again when we
started making this movie Walmart was
the number one music retailer and which
is so crazy itunes and then that fell
out now it's all streaming but I mean
that's what I do I you know I have an RT
account which i love I don't think our
do is absolutely fantastic yeah it's
laid out I think me you and Jonah ray
are like the champions of our do but it
but it's true like I and I described it
as the apple of the streaming services
because it's very clean it's very easy
to do and it's based around the album
yeah it's not just you know here's this
crazy playlist or anything like that
it's pretty pretty self-explanatory but
I use that as like my listening booth
that's my listening station and then if
there's something that I really dig I'll
you know buy it on vinyl just so that I
have it run my collection but I'm a
weird dude so yeah I do the same thing
because like the I mean getting into
vinyl to it sounds so snobby and
pretentious on the top of the like you
click records I'm like it's not about
like showing off about it it's like
about the experience you go to the
record store you buy it either an album
you've always loved or a new one where
you like this would sound good the
ritual of putting it on and then having
to focus on the album yeah oh absolutely
no really again like that the thing that
everyone you know the things that we're
talking about that the thing that you
know people really miss about record
stores and all that stuff really i think
what they're
really talking about is that they miss
being younger and having the time and
energy to really be able to do that yeah
you know when I was you know in 91 92 93
when music was pretty much like the main
thing identified with it was the thing
that I latched onto it like this is who
I'm who I want to be is how I want to be
you know all of those sorts of things
those are all very young things that a
majority of kids do yeah you know they
become obsessive and they want to learn
everything there is to learn about you
know this particular person or this band
and they want to dress like them and
they want to do all that sort of stuff
that's really all you know a very young
way of going about things and though the
thing I keep saying is you know along
the lines of you know it's not better
it's not worse it's just different kids
are still doing that there's you know
wanting to find out you know for lack of
better you know person they still want
to know everything there is to know
about Taylor Swift sure and they want
and it's much easier now for them to
find out stuff about tell ya you don't
have to buy you know a you know kerrang
magazine right or any of these sort of
teeny bopper magazines now to find out
about you know the the artist that
you're into now it's just a different
way of going about it but it's all still
happening it's just now it's a little
bit different you know now it's not
sitting there and looking at the you
know looking at the the covers and
wondering what these people sound like
in conversation because you can go
online yeah and like yeah an interview
with them like that you know what I mean
it's so really when people talk about
all that sort of stuff I just go like
yeah I miss being to get to right yeah I
miss free time for you yeah tell you
like I got six hours to kill I guess
I'll just go to the records you like I
mean I never have six hours the kills
and though the young people don't know
like they they never even like we're
familiar with the things that we missed
anyway were you like no one looks at an
album cover anymore the liner notes but
to them that the to them it's like they
never experienced the album cover liner
notes they just click on these series of
interviews that artists that's there
yeah that's their liner notes thing you
know it's the way I see it is like the
liner notes will really what's replace
liner notes the website well that's what
it is yeah totally I mean I remember you
know when I got to college going to the
the computer lab where you can just go
in and you give me your card you can
just go on the internet yeah you could
surf the web so I would go you know and
the you know was a navigator whatever
Netscape mask ago and all of a sudden go
wait a minute are you telling me all
these people that have like Pink Floyd
websites Yeah right cool I want to find
everything I can find out about that
[ __ ] wall movie that yeah you know
scared the bejesus out of me when I was
a kid or all those albums were they
never printed the lyrics yes and you
could never figure it out so what are
the others answer yeah exactly yeah
exactly and so you know again I'm a big
believer in the power of boredom and
basically just wanting to kill time and
trying to come up with ways of
entertaining yourself there that for
lack of a better phrase are healthy and
and for me you know going to the record
store that was part of it but then I was
you know I'm on that cusp because I was
around when they stopped selling singles
and so you know I was around when the
internet sort of became this thing we're
all of a sudden maybe I wasn't going to
a record store to kill a few hours it
was like going home and sitting on my
computer right going into you know some
AOL chat room you know being a
proposition by people who are probably
45 years old yeah as young kids but uh
but I remember and I remember how
exciting that was and yeah we're the
thing that we would bond over music
total what bands are you listening to oh
I'm listening to the new rancid record
and edit it you know all that sort of
stuff you know
that boredom you know there was a lot
more boredom to be had in yeah seven 60s
and 70s yeah there were three channels
pressure from do you know what I mean
and nothing good was on those three
channels really a majority of the time
so you went outside and it was really
about being bored with your friends
right where'd you go you go to a record
store well now it's a little bit harder
to get bored yeah where do kids loiter
yeah I know we just like going and
sitting outside of a 7-eleven you did a
lawyer online i think the facebook yeah
where they'll order together online yeah
i think like there's let's meet up and
all just hang out on her phone exactly
yeah i think the work they're still like
a transition period right now with that
where people are still trying to figure
out like how much is too much and how
much like real life do i need versus
computer life and was like where's the
balance you know you got yeah i mean you
definitely have to have a balance yeah a
couple of times where I've been like Oh
Lee [ __ ] that was a bender yeah I was
like wow three hours online like the
sun's out I could have taken a walk yeah
I'd like a friend exactly hence why I
walked here ready you know I gotta walk
yeah I go outside it's really nice out
even getting like 10 or 20 minutes of
whatever is like it it breaks you away
from that you let yourself be bored yeah
which is super pretty excited about our
technology so I wonder if that'll change
when it becomes come when it becomes
completely enmeshed in all of our
everyday lives were i still think their
gadgets commit really holy [ __ ] you can
do this you know and maybe that maybe
people will get back to maybe going
outside will become a cool thing and I
think that it's leveled off a little bit
with music cuz it yes when it all went
free everyone went crazy and they were
just like give me like a hundred gigs of
music and then 50 more gigs in a month
and you're like you haven't you haven't
absorbed any of it yeah you're just
taking and taking yeah but I think with
these streaming platforms like minus the
fact that they're ripping off the
artists i mean the artists aren't
getting anything and that sucks it does
that that that sucks but they are they
are adjusting to their learning how to
like all right that's the lay of the
land now there's no way to undo what's
online yeah and and how free or cheap
everything
and they're figuring out other ways
merch and touring and all that stuff and
um but I think people are starting to
finally like slow down a little bit that
like I don't I don't need you like
collect all this [ __ ] because I'm paying
nine ninety-nine a month mm-hmm and I
can just like explore a little bit and
like listen to a full album maybe well
there was an interesting article maybe
about eight or nine months ago that came
out right around the time that we had
locked picture on the tower dock then I
actually thought was really interesting
where they were saying you know it was
along the lines of the the Taylor
Swift's and all them you know taking a
stand with streaming and everything and
and obviously you know you've got your
top you know one percent of the you know
the big-name groups and everything and
you know they need to make waves about
paying to help things up for the little
guy but one of the this article was
talking about the fact that really the
people that benefit the most from
streaming are these obscure acts that
have long been forgotten you know that
are not the most popular thing in the
world but now there's a it's easier for
people to find find it yeah because
these things can now be shared quickly
they can be you know emailed or text or
anything like that and so you have these
artists that are you know not
necessarily you know incredibly well
known that are getting their music out
there and you know some of these artists
or you know haven't been around for 30
years 40 years 50 years yeah and that
when someone like a Taylor Swift or you
know like Dan and Pat from the Black
Keys when they're when they're you know
fighting you know for you know a better
deal on their streaming or you know or
even [ __ ] Radiohead with you know all
the stuff that they've been doing it
really is genuinely for the greater good
of the musician yeah and it really does
affect everybody because there's so many
other artists now that are actually you
know getting a second crack at it yeah
to a degree or a lot of cases a first
crack like
like a band that's living in the in like
Des Moines Iowa like we don't have to
move to LA we don't have to do we can
just make a record here put it online
it's really good like we stand more of a
chance than like in 1998 oh absolutely
like three record companies they've
created stars they made way too much
money yeah and then everyone else had
nothing yeah so now it's like connivance
it's more of an even playing field yeah
and the less money thing people always
like to compare it to like we're not
making what you used to it's like they
were like nine big stars making like a
hundred million dollars a year and
you're like it and then the record
companies were making outrageous money
um it's incredible yeah it really is
incredible yeah they compared to that
and you're like that was over that was
the other extreme yeah and then it went
free which was like well no one's saying
that either balayya let's find somewhere
in the middle well I mean and you know
the other the other aspect of this that
has always been incredibly fascinating
to me is that you know my day job of
wearing makeup and pretending to be
other people that whole industry has
been looking at the music industry and
saying how do we avoid this right how do
we how do we stop this from happening
mm-hmm what do we do so that we don't
implode like like they did yeah and you
know to a degree I think you know the
film or TV industry whatever you want to
call it has done a well considerably
better job at sort of co-opting and
embracing the fact that this technology
is not going away yeah and trying to
make the technology work for them in a
manner that that makes sense you know
what I mean because really ultimately
the thing that is so weird is that the
music industry which is multifaceted
writers there's the merchandise element
there's the touring component like
there's a there's a bunch of facets to
the music engine but the music industry
said like the only way this can be
consumed is this one way right with a CD
that's the only way
yeah and that you know I mean they just
said okay well if you're saying that
that's the only way we'll just go around
that completely and now with the you
know with the with the film industry
they're saying like well no it's not you
don't just have to go see movies you
don't just have to go see you know see
it on DVD you don't just have to see it
on streaming will come up with as many
different platforms as we possibly can
yeah and that sort of is working you
know to a degree you know where you look
at Public Radio and what public radio
has done they never said like you can
only listen to this on this one
frequency read on a radio they said no
we find ways to do it yeah we'll put it
online we'll make it a podcast exactly
huh music industry was incredibly
stubborn as they lost that battle well
yeah man because they were making a [ __ ]
ton of money there was so much money I
mean didn't want to lose one of our
guests a long time we aren't using art
director who's the head of the art
department at RCA for years and just to
talk to him about video budgets it's
incredible he's like you don't
understand like I we used to make a
million-dollar music video and it was
like not a big deal like we the kind of
money was just so insane that you get
why that many people hung on to it like
everyone was just like A&R guys everyone
was bloated it was the coup and it was
not only everyone's getting rich it was
the coolest job to have fun job most
jobs where you get credibly richer kinda
boring like a lawyer some [ __ ] yeah like
if you not only would you get to like
dress like that my friend never not wore
a leather jacket and he was had a
coolest [ __ ] job everyone looked cool
and was loaded yeah yeah most rich
people don't need to like I'm gonna hang
out with Keith Richards today for work
yeah they're always just in a room on a
conference call it sucks yeah and that
you know I mean at the end of the day
which i think is a phrase I've used a
few times this afternoon but that was
oddly one of the things that really
ended up being an important sort of
theme for the the doc which was you know
here are these people that they weren't
musicians they weren't big label people
these were
just regular kids that wanted to get a
job in the music industry they were able
to get in at the ground level and they
were able to find a company where they
could work for 30-plus years have
insurance you know yeah live the life
that they sort of wanted to live have a
whole lot of [ __ ] fun doing it yeah
and it it wasn't a place that they hate
it to work yeah and how special and
unique that is to have a job that you
love to have people that you like to
work with to be able to say you know oh
you know I worked at the store when
Elton John came in and would buy the all
these records and all those fascinating
footage no that's that's that foot it
just is nuts you know all of that I mean
that's that's that's a really special
thing and these weren't you know
necessarily the coolest kids and in you
know in class these were the guys are
just like I love this this is what I
want to do and I like having a good time
and I like to work and so I'm gonna do
that and they ended up getting to
experience the music industry for 34
years can I ask and it wasn't mentioned
in the documentary and I want to know if
it was intentional or not what those
people ended up doing after after tower
close you know I wanted to kind of get
into it but once you get into that then
the stories start splintering right i
mean because some people stayed sort of
in the like Heidi kotler for example she
stayed within the book world um but like
Stan gum and he went and opened up like
a copying shop like a sign making shop
uh-huh but then that closed and so by
the time we had started they some people
had already had like stutters stops with
you know what they were doing next and
then within seven years it's just like I
I can't mention what they're all doing
because they all sort of split
so it was really much more about not
what they do after the band breaks up
but wanting to stick with the band
breaking up yeah and hopefully you know
it's a little bit of a cheat I will I
will totally admit but hopefully people
would wonder what they did right and
would get that you know I mean if I can
just get them to care about what they
did right afterwards great yeah then you
leave them wanting a little bit more
sure what I mean are also like a pop
song like yeah them wanting more left
you more focused on what they did for
that 35 years instead of like cuz
sometimes it doesn't always you know and
upgrade they didn't like go on to
another bigger better things you don't
want to leave going like although that
poor guy yeah because the way they were
talking about the place it's like they
they loved their light they love that 35
years of like this was the coolest thing
I could have ever done yeah like I loved
every minute of it and then you know all
things must pass yes well like even r us
when we started the documentary he had
opened up another record store oh no way
I opened up another record store in
Sacramento that was the location of one
of the Tower Records up there well
what's a call it was called are five
records are phone okay um and I think it
may be last like two years right I don't
went bankrupt did he did the founders
like the main founders did they stay did
they get incredibly rich and stay rich
or is it the kind of thing we're like as
it went down they stayed in too long no
here's here's what here's what i can say
they're financially fine okay good
personal it bothers me so much all the
four or five main yeah well Russ is fine
yum you know of the the main group there
everyone is you know they're still
working and you know they've all got
their own different jobs yeah they're
all you know still employed trying to
you know make their way I mean they're
not they're not living a lattice home
lifestyle ok cats homeless but they
think God they're not resting on there
on their accomplishments by any means if
they still got out but a hundred ninety
stores wouldn't at some point someone
was making incredible amounts of money I
mean they definitely made a lot of money
right but it's also over a large spent
you know it's bet it's a large span of
time yeah I mean they're one of the
interesting sort of one of the
interesting things that we sort of
pulled from when everyone was sort of
getting fired and that corporate
restructuring people came in is one of
the ways that they tried to save money
was okay well if someone is making two
hundred thousand dollars a year let's
fire that person and we can hire two
people at one hundred thousand right
okay so if I'm just going to go off that
number two hundred thousand grand that's
pretty good for a year that is that
that's a lot of money but you know in
2006 you know has that person been
saving up you're a bad person been you
know fiscally responsible in their own
life yeah I don't know I didn't I didn't
necessarily really feel it was my place
to ask those questions so I look that
the main thing is is that when they all
lost their jobs and you know some lost
their jobs you know prior to the stores
actually closing but regardless
eventually they all lost their jobs they
all had a major readjustment period yeah
and some of them handled it a little bit
better than others I'm not saying that
anyone handled it incredibly poorly but
it was all a big wake-up call you know
because again there's this point they
the company never the company saw growth
every year from 1960 until around two
thousand four I couldn't believe that
when they said that it always made money
doesn't always that's so rare there was
no preparing for us why would they ever
think you never think that it's there
was no well this reminds me of when it
happened it never [ __ ] there are more
conversations like
wouldn't i buy another Porsche yeah yeah
it is not to say that it was always
peaches and cream like there were years
where you know the music industry was
taking a dive or there were issues that
they were having and it looked like
things might maybe change but then
something would happen that would pull
them out of that you know what I mean
and so when you're talking about that
kind of success for 30-plus years yeah
yeah you know you don't necessarily
think I mean I get comfortable after you
know a couple of awesome days in a row
i'm like great dude I got things made up
for a happy yeah oh my god they were
doing very very well for a very long
time yeah that's amazing yeah and it's
cool that um I mean I I like that you
just focus more on like the place and
like in and how they all felt working
there like what it did as far as like
just the numbers and all that stuff and
I think you just used to at the end of a
document are going like well what
happened cuz is always liked and
morehouse Owens of course but it didn't
it didn't like it didn't really matter
yeah cuz you're just like that's it was
such a unique company and such a cool
way of running it yeah like you see that
you go why isn't every CEO exactly
Russell eggs I don't they get it ya know
what why can't more businesses the take
from this yeah and improve upon it you
know that was that was really sort of
eye-opening i mean when i first met Russ
so it ties into what we were talking
about earlier when you think like the
CEO of this huge company is going to be
yeah she's gonna wear suit and have a
scar and be like what is it kid you know
yeah say the word like bottom line all
right yeah I met Russ he's like you know
golf shirt comfy shoes it's like what
are you guys doing you guys are crazy
yeah let's go is really the antithesis
that's the exact attitude that made that
put a hundred and ninety stores like hey
Chewie let's go check it out all right
yeah yeah here yeah building why not um
and that ended up being sort of one of
the ways i ended up making this movie is
I just sort of emulated what rust it you
know I got really smart people around me
and let them do their job and I didn't
you know micromanage stuff I you know I
told them what I wanted I told them you
know and basically when I would say what
I wanted I would say here's what I don't
want all right because that's tends to
be how I operate you know I don't want
you no I don't want a narrator I don't
want you know famous people the first
three minutes saying white towers
important here's you know this is the
one of the facts I want to make this is
one of the things I want to drive home
this is the vibe i want to feel when
we're talking about the sunset store
having those conversations and then you
know letting you know Darren or editor
go yeah letting uh Steven our writer you
know ask certain questions that maybe I
wasn't necessarily thinking about at the
time but he's journalist I'm just a due
to wears makeup for a living I'm just
acting like I'm the director so let's
just let's too late now you are a
director now yeah now you are a direct
better for worse well I'm damned hyphen
it's I know yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna said
you want to direct it out more now you
want to like do you have like in the
seven-year period where you're like I'm
loving this I can think of other
subjects i'm passionate about that i
could do a doc on there are a couple of
other subjects that I've definitely been
toying with and so is it it's definitely
something that I want to do again I
learned a lot in the the time it's taken
for us to make this movie yeah and I've
even used some of those lessons to sort
of direct like these I've done a couple
of short docs hmm directed a short doc
for ESPN 30 for 30 s and about the
Giants mascot is God yeah
the anti mascot and and produced a
couple of was as well so I'm a little
bit more knowledgeable about how this
stuff works but in terms of like taking
on another feature documentary I
definitely want to do it but I need to
find the subject yeah that really gets
me supremely excited and for whatever
reason that that you know I got
incredibly lucky with tower like I just
got very very lucky that no one else was
making this documentary and for whatever
reason I just had to do it yeah and
hopefully I'll be able to find another
subject like that you know I've got a
few ideas but nothing really I have an
idea but I'm going to tell you after
we're done okay yeah so it's now that's
no one can steal it no one's on a dirty
position so it it is out right now and
it's la New York it's la New York it's
expanding every week so people can go to
Tower Records movie calm and find out
where it is playing in theaters and then
if you if we're not in your town you can
it'll it again sir yeah it'll exist in
other shapes and focus down and then on
Twitter it is a tower records doc yes at
Tower Records dog you are at Colin Hanks
1l not 21 l not too and then tau with
the website one more time uh Tower
Records movie comm Tower Records movie
calm cool this has been cool this has
been cool thanks man you enjoy it's
ready I did yeah it's a little
conversation yeah yes three dude yes
three days three dudes talking music
talking dog like yeah I know you're
super busy dude and thank you for taking
the time my pleasure do this absolutely
everyone go see this documentary it's
amazing